[Music]
welcome in everybody to montgomery and
company i'm renee montgomery you're back
at it again with the fam and listen
we're gonna have a little heart to heart
everybody all right we gotta talk about
some things access is one of the first
things we're going to talk about why
because it breeds opportunities so if
you have opportunity and you have access
let's share it
[Music]
as a woman sometimes you don't feel like
any place is your right place because in
the business place people may not make
you feel as comfortable they may not
make you feel like oh my leadership in
sports doesn't carry over to business
or yeah we know you're a good analyst
but this is the nba so being a woman you
don't necessarily feel like you're
exactly where you should be but i really
did when i became a co-owner
she's connected by atnt is so necessary
for young girls because when you think
about access and the amount of
opportunities that young girls may get
as opposed to young boys there's a
dramatic difference
what up what up what up
hello there what's up i'm renee hi nice
to meet you
so this is where it goes down right here
being connected i think is what women
are gonna have to do we're gonna have to
build together we'll have to grow
together we're gonna have to build our
own community we could have a guest
being interviewed here if you get in
hold the door open and get some more
people in
to become co-owner and vice president of
the atlanta dream a team that i was just
playing for being a black woman sitting
in an ownership box feels abnormal but i
hope that these things start to become
normalized where you see women doing
everything and
we can
i love the concept of change makers they
give visibility to women's sports you
know what as a brand women's sports is
hot and so somebody in broadcast media
has to lean in i'm really excited so we
have three dope young ladies all
graduated from colleges around atlanta
spelman clark georgia state they're all
interested in the media entertainment
space and hello that's right where i am
i think the thing about mentoring that
excites me is that i know that we can
help them what is it like or how are you
able to balance being an owner of a team
and a sports broadcaster it's all about
time management so it's like we only
have a certain amount of time in the day
and not be planning that timeout how do
you handle working like under pressure
playing basketball playing sports really
helped me with that because
there's been times where it's like all
right i gotta shoot this shot either we
win the game we lose the game if i make
this shot so that's pressure right most
of my background is in live theater
however i am interested in film and
television but i think as a black queer
woman i struggle with imposter syndrome
and sometimes that stops me from taking
risks fear is always going to be there
in a sense of like it's always going to
be scary to start something new or do
something new but the way that i always
get through stuff is just remind myself
why do you want to do in the first place
access and opportunity is everything you
can't get your first job until somebody
gives you your first job like so how do
you get your first job and so that's
kind of why i wanted to start the
mentorship program with our mentees i'm
going to make sure that we get them
opportunities whatever it is that they
want to do you got it so i would like to
offer you guys our initiation of the
renee montgomery enterprise mentorship
program absolutely yeah we want to be
able to give you guys a taste of the
real life experiences that you want so
if you want to be a producer you can
shadow our montgomery and company
producer for our podcast you know like
if you want to get into entertainment we
have so many things where you could
perform at in front of a crowd if you
don't have the right resources if you
don't have the right access how can you
excel and so we want to give them
everything that they need to excel and
at t has done that all right this is the
beginning
y'all better
atnt is providing rme with tablets
phones att fiber software everything
that can help support our small business
as well as support the girls that we're
going to be mentoring so it's really
exciting
[Music]
i'm renee montgomery signing out i'll
see you next time
let's go